ça normal l'exploit à nouveau format le
format que nous avons retenu ces deux
centres et notre
manifestation sur l'excellence la
production locale nous avons fait un
choix délibéré lavoine espace plus
restreint d'avoir un angle plus
restreint exposants et de montrer ce que
nous faisons de mieux en martinique à
terme de d'excellence de production en
termes d'innovation et donc le salon
nous l'avons décomposé en plusieurs
pôles ou regrouper l'ensemble du ski
locale
c'est un salon qui se fait en
partenariat depuis toujours avec la mpt
john parkes sûr de lui et nous allons
souhaitée complet cette manifestation
avec la scène la 14ème conférence de
coopération régionale cela permet aux
acteurs locaux d'être en contact avec
les invités qui sont venus de sept
conférences de rencontres et conférences
be to be aux réunions be to be les
ambassadeurs de la zone
et beurre d'avoir des informations
qu'ils auront ce n'était le marché et
car ali c'est un choix délibéré d'avoir
un espace plus restreint avec une
production de qualité est exceptionnelle
on sort quand même
l'engouement du public pour la
valorisation de tout ce qui est fait ici
nous avons une des marques locales qui
sont très forts c'est le travail de
l'abbaye qui paye fait travailler sur la
marque pile produits de l'industrie
locale qui aujourd'hui porte ses fruits
avec une l'appropriation très forte de
partie des quais de la principale marque
notamment dans le secteur
agroalimentaire